[Musik]
Konferenz ja Markus Söder in der
bayerischen Staatskanzlei mit einer
Erklärung zu Hubert einwanger ob er ihn
im Amt beläst oder entlässt vor
Abmeldungen verschiedener Medien eher
beläst ihn im Amt getroffen
ich habe es mit dabei nicht leicht
gemacht glauben Sie es mir
und ich möchte sie teilhaben lassen an
meinem Abwägungsprozess der am Ende zu
den Entscheidung geführt hat
es ging und geht um schwere Vorwürfe
Antisemitismus hat keinen Platz in
Bayern
ist ein Bollwerk gegen Rassismus und
Antisemitismus
das garantiere ich persönlich als
bayerischer Ministerpräsident
da ist das Flugblatt besonders ekelig
widerwärtig
menschenverachtend und absoluter
nazi-schaltung
die Vorwürfe die in dem Zusammenhang mit
diesem Flugplatz im Raum stehen Schaden
Bayern müssen deswegen ernsthaft
bewertet und beantwortet werden
ich habe in den letzten Tagen und vor
allem letzten Stunden genau abgewogen
mir war dabei wichtig ein faires
geordnetes Verfahren zu finden und nicht
nur nach Medienberichten zu entscheiden
angemessen aufgrund der Vorwürfe aber
auch fair gegenüber der Person Hubert
Aiwanger und ganz bewusst keine
Vorverurteilung vorzunehmen
da haben wir an Hubert albaumer 25
Fragen gestellt seine Antworten seine
äußere Öffentlichkeit und ein langes
persönliches Gespräch gestern Abend
sind jetzt die Basis für die Abwägung
Entscheidung
vorab muss man sagen leider war sein
Krisenmanagement der letzten Woche nicht
sehr glücklich
er hätte angesichts des Vorwurfs des
Antisemitismus früher
entschlossener umfassender aufklären
müssen
erst alles abzustreiten teilweise Dinge
zuzugestehen manche Widersprüche das hat
die Glaubwürdigkeit in dieser Woche
nicht erhöht spät aus meiner Sicht nicht
zu spät gab es aber eine klare
Entschuldigung und eine klare
Distanzierung dies war überfällig aber
es war richtig und notwendig
weil die eigenveraufklärung am Anfang
jedoch zu schleppend war haben wir 25
Fragen gestellt zu dem Flugblatt aber
auch zu anderen Vorwürfen aus dieser
Zeit
alle Fragen wurden beantwortet und
zeitgerecht übermittelt
die Fragen und Antworten werden aus
Gründen der Transparenz im Anschluss
dieses Statements veröffentlicht sowohl
an die anwesenden Journalisten als auch
im Netz zur Verfügung gestellt dies ist
ausdrücklich mit dem Einverständnis von
Hubert Aiblinger sogar auf sein Wunsch
hin passiert oder wird passieren
zum Inhalt der Fragen die dann auch
jeder noch mal selbst beantworten kann
aber ich sage meine Bewertung
die Antwort war nicht alle befriedigend
es war viel Bekanntes wenig Neues
und einiges ist auch nicht der innerlich
oder vieles ist nicht der innerlich
zu seinen Gunsten will und muss man
auslegen will ich und muss man auslegen
dass er sich erneut von dem Flugblatt
distanziert hat dass er das bereut
Gefühle mögliche Gefühle verletzt zu
haben
und in dem sehr langen persönlichen
Gespräch das kann ich ihnen darstellen
hat er mir mehrfach versichert das
Flugblatt sei nicht von ihm
man merkt übrigens sehr und ich habe es
bemerkt wie sehen die ganze Sache
belastet und doch persönlich anfasst
und neu in der Beantwortung der Fragen
ist dass er den Vorfall insgesamt seiner
Schulzeit als ein einschneidendes
Erlebnis betrachtet und Zitat dass dies
bei ihm wichtige gedankliche Prozesse
angestoßen hat
nach meiner Bewertung aller vorliegenden
Fakten stellt es für mich am Ende so da
erstens
er hat in seiner Jugend wohl schwere
Fehler gemacht
dass auch zugestanden
er hat sich dafür zweitens entschuldigt
davon distanziert und auch Reue gezeigt
drittens ein Beweis jedoch dass er das
Flugblatt verfasst oder verbreitet hat
gibt es bis heute nicht
dagegen steht seine ganz klare Erklärung
dass er es nicht war
viertens
seit dem Vorfall von damals gibt es
nichts vergleichbares
fünftens das ganze ist in der Tat 35
Jahre her
kaum einer von uns ist heute noch so wie
er mit 16 war
daher in der Gesamtabwägung
dass kein Beweis vorliegt dass die Sache
35 Jahre her ist und das seitdem nichts
Vergleichbares vorgefallen ist wäre eine
Entlassung aus dem Amt aus meiner Sicht
nicht verhältnismäßig
aber einfach Schwamm drüber oder ein
weiter so wäre auch der falsche Weg
natürlich sind viele Gefühle verletzt zu
viel Schaden entstanden und zu viel
Glaubwürdigkeit verloren
daher mein Ernst und gut gemeinter Rat
auch wenn all die Sachen lang her sind
ist es wichtig die Reue und die Demut zu
zeigen
ich finde es ist nicht entscheidend
allein was man mit 16 sagt
sondern wie man als 52-Jährige damit
heute umgeht
und wer ernsthaft bereut der kann auch
leichter auf Verzeihung hoffen
wir haben daher auch gestern Abend nicht
nur persönlich miteinander geredet
sondern hatten auch eine gemeinsame
koalitionsausschussitzung
und haben intensiv die Situation und die
Zukunft besprochen
wir waren alle der gemeinsamen
Auffassung das ist wichtig ist das
Hubert Aiwanger war dann arbeitet
verloren gegangenes Vertrauen
zurückzugewinnen so dass er auch
Gespräche mit jüdischen Gemeinden suchen
sollte
und vieles zu erklären und gemeinsam zu
besprechen es sieht es im übrigen auch
persönlich genauso
wir haben dies auch mit Frau Knobloch
und dann Schuster heute morgen noch
besprochen
ich weiß
meine Entscheidung wird nicht allen
gefallen
bei einigen bleiben Restzweifel
aber ich betone noch einmal das Ergebnis
ist
die Abwägung eines fairn und geordnet
Verfahrens ich empfinde es als Augenmaß
statt Übermaß oder vorvorteilung
damit steht auch fest werden in Bayern
die bürgerliche Koalition fortsetzen
können
es wird definitiv in Bayern kein
Schwarz-Grün geben und alle Angebote der
Opposition die so gemacht werden laufen
ins Leere
und wir konzentrieren uns wieder auf das
Wesentliche
es gibt nicht um eine Person in Bayern
sondern es geht um andere große Fragen
und Sorgen die Mehrzahl der Menschen
hatte Sorgen um die wirtschaftliche
Entwicklung in Deutschland
zum Schluss
das war eine unschöne Woche es hat
Bayern geschadet
glauben Sie mir das fiel mir auch
persönlich alles nicht leicht
ich wollte aber neutral und fair
und doch hat nachhaltig mit der
Situation umgehen
die Koalition wurde durch die
Berichterstattung um die Freien Wählern
Hubert Aiwanger natürlich belastet
ich habe als Ministerpräsident die
Aufgabe Schaden vom Land zu nehmen
Schaden auch zu begrenzen und vor allem
eine stabile Regierung für dieses starke
ein wundervolle Land zu gewährleisten
das habe ich nach besten Wissen und
Gewissen getan
meine sehr verehrten Damen und Herren
ich bedauere diese Angelegenheit
damit ist die Sache aber aus meiner
Sicht abgeschlossen meine Entscheidung
steht ich werde den Abgeordneten der
Koalition empfehlen für den kommenden
Donnerstag am Landtag entsprechend mit
dieser Entscheidung zu verfahren
herzlichen Dank und in allen noch einen
schönen Sonntag
vielen Dank für Interesse
ja soweit Markus Söder der bayerische
Ministerpräsident mit der von allen mit
Spannung erwarteten Erklärung wie er
denn jetzt mit seinem Stellvertreter mit
Hubert Albaner von den Freien Wählern
verfärbt Liebe ZuschauerInnen liebe
Zuschauer sie haben das gesehen er wird
nicht entlassen das hat Markus Söder
auch begründet er hat zwar gesagt dass
Hubert alwanger mit seinem Verhalten und
mit dem ganzen Sachverhalt Bayern
geschadet hat aber und seine Performance
das heißt also das was wie Hubert
Aiwanger mit diesen Vorwürfen in der
letzten Woche umgegangen ist alles
andere als glücklich war aber er hat
sich spät nicht zu spät zu Reue und
Distanzierung entschlossen er hat sich
entschuldigt das liegt auch kein Beweis
vor dass er dieses unsägliche Flugblatt
verfasst hat und das ganze ist auch 35
Jahre her und deswegen wäre eine
Entlastung eine Entlassung von Hubert
eiwanger aus dem Amt des bayerischen
Wirtschaftsministers und
stellvertretenden Ministerpräsidenten
unverhältnismäßig wer sich ausdrückt hat
der bayerische Ministerpräsident hat
Hubert Aiwanger auch empfohlen zum
Beispiel das Gespräch mit jüdischen
Gemeinden zu suchen in dem Zusammenhang
ist viele auch der Name der Vorsitzenden
der jüdischen Gemeinde in München
Charlotte Knobloch und des Vorsitzenden
des Präsidenten des Zentralrats der
Juden in Deutschland Josef Schuster all
das was wir jetzt gerade gehört haben
das wollen wir noch einordnen mit einem
geschmackspass der mir jetzt hoffentlich
zugeschaltet ist Albrecht von Lucke
Publizist und Journalist guten Morgen
kann man ja noch sagen Herr von Lucke
was ist ihre erste Einschätzung dieser
Erklärung von Markus Söder er entlässt
Hubert Aiwanger nicht er beläst ihn im
Amt er hat zwar schwere Fehler bei ihm
entdeckt und die auch klar benannt aber
er bleibt im Amt diese Entscheidung
nachvollziehbar ist sie durch den
Landtagswahl und den Landtagswahlkampf
vielleicht auch entscheiden mit
beeinflusst wie sehen Sie das
ja sie ist in meinen Augen in der Sache
durchaus überzeugend um nicht zu sagen
richtig aber natürlich all das ist auch
immer politisch mit motiviert um es am
Anfang zu Beginn ja ich finde es völlig
richtig fand die Argumentation von
Markus Söder auch stark er hat
tatsächlich ein durchaus sehr ernsten
abwägungsvorgang vorgezogen man sei ja
auch es war alles sehr genau schriftlich
notiert nicht wie von Söder sonst in
freier Rede vorgetragen und die
Argumente sind in der Sache durchaus
überzeugend er musste immer abwägen
inwieweit auch vor allem eine Entlassung
von Herrn Aiwanger dazu geführt hätte
dass der Opfer Mythos an dem Herr
Aiwanger jetzt ja schon arbeitet weiter
zugeschlagen ist es musste also ganz
enorme Gründe dafür geben ihn zu
entlassen die sind mit den starken
Argumenten dass es einerseits
tatsächlich 35 Jahre her ist dass er
Albaner sich auch Markus Söder hat das
sehr deutlich gesagt nach ausgesprochen
in Schwierigkeiten und es noch mal zu
wiederholen und noch stärker zu machen
nach einer Phase in der er Zweifel an
seinem Verständnis der Angelegenheit hat
erzeugen müssen beziehungsweise erzeugt
hat Herr Aiwanger sich entschuldigt nach
eben geraumer Zeit großen
Anlaufschwierigkeiten wenn ich es so
salopp sagen darf aber dann kam die
Entschuldigung und der mitentscheidende
dritte Grund seit dieser Jugendzeit im
Alter von 16 Jahren ist vergleichbares
nicht passiert das heißt ja nicht dass
Aiwanger nicht durchaus
rechtspopulistisch die jüngsten Erding
aufgetreten wäre wo er durchaus sehr
afda ein populistischen Ton anschlägt
wir müssen uns die Demokratie
zurückholen das ist aber in der Sache
nicht vergleichbar mit diesem damaligen
Flugplatz der Umstand dass Aiwanger auch
reich war dass er gezeigt hat dass er
einsehen hat man wunderte sich auch da
ein Stück weit in der Korrektur denn
Markus Söder gab zu verstehen dass er
jetzt plötzlich Ellwanger das zu einem
ein zu einem ja wie sagte er zu einem
einschneiden Erlebnis erklärte das
damalige Flugblatt das Zeug ja immerhin
im Nachhinein davon dass er
offensichtlich die schwere jetzt
wahrscheinlich auch oder nachdem er es
verdrängt hatte nachdem er sicherlich
auch erhoffte der Fluch würde an ihm
vorbei gegangen dass er jetzt die
Dimension begriffen hat das alles sind
starke Gründe dafür ihm anzulassen aber
das ist natürlich immer auch politisch
hochgradig motiviert Markus Söder so
sehr dass in der Sache meines Erachtens
richtig ist weil man ansonsten Herrn
Aiwanger und den Freien Wählern eher den
Opfermythos zugespielt hätte und auch in
der Bevölkerung es nicht hätte recht
verständlich machen können dass nachdem
er sich entschuldigt hat er entlassen
wird es ist natürlich Schwermut
politisch motiviert und das war für mein
Verständnis auch die schwächste Stelle
von Markus Söder er hatte es eigentlich
nicht nötig ja darf ich eine Nachfrage
stellen also sie hat gesagt einerseits
Treue und entschuldigung das hat er
gezeigt am Donnerstag durch diese
Erklärung im gleichen Atemzug hat er
aber eine von einer Kampagne sogar von
einer Vernichtung seiner politischen
Existenz gesprochen wenn ein Politiker
so reagiert und zwei völlig
unterschiedliche Botschaften loslässt er
hat ja immerhin ein wichtiges Amt der
ist Parteivorsitzender in einer
zumindest in Bayern nicht gerade kleinen
Partei was hat das was macht das mit dem
politischen Verantwortungsbewusstsein
einer solchen Person nach außen hin
das ist natürlich auch eine Reaktion im
Übermaß gewesen und man wird sehen
Markus Söder hat es ja angedeutet
inwieweit her Aiwanger jetzt in der Lage
ist tatsächlich so etwas wie Reue zu
zeigen auch das Gespräch zu suchen das
sind ja gewissermaßen auch
Verpflichtungen auf die Zukunft die
jetzt eingegangen ist das war sicher
indiskutabel das war übrigens um es klar
zu sagen sofort die Instrumentalisierung
des Vorgangs durch Herrn Aiwanger man
wird also auch die nächsten großen
bierzeltauftritte die ja schon morgen
mit Killer muss beginnen werden von ihm
beobachten müssen um zu sehen ob er
wirklich begriffen hat und nicht wieder
instrumentalisiert aber man darf auch
eines nicht erkennen es ist ja
tatsächlich so dass das ist in den
letzten Tagen und Wochen ja auch zum
Ausdruck gekommen das ist tatsächlich
einige Menschen im Umfeld von Albaner
gab ein früherer Lehrer und andere die
die zitiert sehr gedrängt haben dass das
jetzt zum Vorschein kam manches ist in
der vorab Mitteilung er wäre der Autor
dieses Flugplatzes gewesen auch am Ende
nicht beweisbar gewesen das war ja mit
der entscheidende Punkt auf den Markus
Söder abstellte ein Beweis nicht
erbracht worden kann wahrscheinlich auch
gar nicht mehr erbracht werden der
einzige der ist vielleicht anders
artikulieren könnte wäre der Bruder
Helmut Aiwanger der sich ja jetzt zum
Verfasser ausgegeben hat also wir sagen
in der Sache sind das meines Erachtens
nicht die entscheidenden Gründe die
hätten dazu führen dürfen ihn zu
entlassen aber was Markus Söder finde
ich im Überschwang und da kam dann sein
eigenes politisches Interesse
ausgesprochen zum Ausdruck dann wieder
deutlich machte es wird keine
schwarz-grüne Koalition in Bayern geben
das ist der eigentliche Kardinal
strategische Grund den er hat er wollte
natürlich einmal auch unbedingt in
seinem Team halten um die angeblich
bürgerliche Koalition man muss den
bürgerlichkeitsbegriff natürlich jetzt
schon ob das Rechtspopulismus von Herrn
ein Stück weit in Frage stellen aber er
hält natürlich unbedingt an dieser
Koalition fest weil er ansonsten sein
ganzes waldstrategisches Konzept
umwerfen müsste und das hat er noch
einmal wie ich will ganz kurz nachfragen
es ging ja nicht nur darum ob Hubert
Aiwanger die Kurve gekriegt sondern ob
auch Markus Söder die Kurve das haben
sie jetzt gerade ange deutet mit den
Koalitionsfragen wenn jetzt nicht noch
eine große Überraschung passiert dann
wird es wahrscheinlich nach den
Landtagswahlen auch für eine Mehrheit
reichen aus CSU und Freien Wähler eine
Fortsetzung dieser Koalition kann wieder
einfach nach dieser Vorgeschichte so
weitermachen wird allwanger deinem Amt
bleiben wie geht's Söder damit um wie
wird auch die CSU mit den Freien Wählern
in Zukunft nach der Landtagswahl
zusammenarbeiten können
naja gucken wir uns die CSU an die ist
bekanntlich eine machtmaschine und in
der Tat Markus Söder hat sich jetzt
derartig auf die Fortsetzung dieser
Koalition vor festgelegt und wenn er auf
der
causaiwanger jetzt nicht an andere
Dingen noch mal einschlagen und nicht
deutlich würde man kann ja übrigens auch
gespannt sein wie wir und das wird jetzt
ja werden sich viele Journalisten über
die Beantwortung der Fragen beugen wie
das ausgeht aber wenn nichts weiteres
auftaucht hat sich Markus Söder Kardinal
darauf festgelegt dass diese angeblich
bürgerliche Koalition fortgesetzt wird
und das halte ich schon wieder
seinerseits für eine erstaunliche
Abwertung einer schwarz-grünen Koalition
man muss sich schon sehr wundern das was
beispielsweise in Nordrhein-Westfalen
offensichtlich mit Herrn wüst und einer
grünen Partei gut gelingt was übrigens
auch einer Voraussicht nach nach der
nächsten Bundestagswahl der Fall sein
würde nämlich Markus Söder wenn ihr denn
übrigens Kanzlerkandidat würde was er
meines Erachtens durchaus weiter im
Schilder führt dann müsste es schwarz
grün sein dass er sich so Kardinal auf
diese Freien Wähler festigt und
gewissermaßen die Grünen Bub erklärt und
eine schwarz-grüne Koalition vorab
verdammt das ist schon erstaunlich das
zeigt wie sehr natürlich auch dieses
belassen von Aiwanger im Amt auch
parteistrategisch motiviert ist er will
auf Gedeih und Verderb an dieser
Koalition festhalten weil er weiß sonst
würde sein ganzes Konzept fallen er hat
sich auf die Grünen regelrecht
eingeschossen und das ist dann schon
politisch ausgesprochen fragwürdig wenn
er einerseits eine causereiwanger ich
meine ja durchaus mit richtigen
Argumenten nicht zum Rücktritt fahren
lassen sieht aber trotzdem nachdem er so
groß die Schwierigkeit mit Aiwanger ja
doch deutlich gemacht hat indem er sich
dann so an ihn fesselt das ist
parteistrategie das ist aber aus
staatssaison oder auch aus bayerischer
Saison nicht recht nachvollziehbar und
das macht meines Erachtens die Schwäche
seiner Argumentation aus er von Luke wir
wollen vielleicht noch einen Schritt
zurückgehen und nochmal genau schauen
was hat eigentlich jetzt zu dieser
Entscheidung geführt ein wesentlicher
Grund war ja offensichtlich nicht nur
die Beantwortung der 25 Fragen die jetzt
Markus Söder offensichtlich ja
ausgereicht hat sondern auch die
Erklärung von Donnerstag wir sind da
gerade ja selbst schon drauf eingegangen
wir zeigen noch mal diese kurze
Erklärung Hubert Aiwanger am Donnerstag
in der Bayerischen
Wirtschaftsministerium wo er sich zum
ersten Mal dezidiert zu den Vorwürfen
äußert hat und auch sich entschuldigt
hat und auch Reue gezeigt hat
in den vergangenen Tagen hat es
zahlreiche Vorwürfe gegen mich gegeben
es geht um ein abscheuliches Pamphlet
das vor 36 Jahren in meiner Schultasche
gefunden wurde und es sind Aussagen
aufgetaucht die den Eindruck vermitteln
ich wäre als Jugendlicher auf einen
menschenfeindlichen Weg geraten ich habe
als jugendlich auch Fehler gemacht ich
bereue zutiefst wenn ich durch mein
Verhalten in Bezug auf das in Rede
stehende Pamphlet oder weitere Vorwürfe
gegen mich aus der Jugendzeit Gefühle
verletzt habe meine aufrichtige
Entschuldigung gilt zuvor dass da ein
Opfern des Ines Regimes deren
Hinterbliebenen und allen Beteiligten
und der wertvollen Erinnerungsarbeit
die genannten Vorwürfe liegen 36 Jahre
zurück ich betone nochmals ich habe das
beim Fleet nicht verfasst ich
distanziere mich in jeder Form von dem
ekelhaften Inhalt ich war nie ein
Antisemit ich war nie ein
menschenvereint
die Vorwürfe haben mich erschreckt ich
kann mich nicht erinnern jemals einen
Hitlergruß gezeigt zu haben ich habe
keine Hitler reden vor dem Spiegel
einstudiert weitere Vorwürfe wie
menschenfeindliche Witze kann ich aus
meiner Erinnerung wieder vollständig
dementieren auch bestätigen sollte dies
geschehen sein so entschuldige ich mich
dafür in aller Form es ist jedoch nicht
akzeptabel dass diese Verfehlungen jetzt
in einer politischen Kampagne gegen mich
und meine parteiinstrumentalisiert
werden ich habe den Eindruck ich soll
politisch und persönlich fertig gemacht
werden es ist ein negatives Bild von mir
in den letzten Tagen gezeichnet worden
das bin nicht ich das ist nicht Hubert
wie gesagt diese Erklärung von Hubert
Aiwanger hat möglicherweise mit dazu
beigetragen dass Markus Söder ihn jetzt
auch im Amt des bayerischen
Wirtschaftsministers beläst und auch
seine Stellvertreters das haben wir
gerade gehört es geht ja auch noch darum
dass jetzt Markus Söder hat das
angekündigt die 25 Fragen die er ihm
gestellt hat zu diesem Vorgang um dieses
unsägliche Flugblatt ja veröffentlicht
werden soll einschließlich der Antworten
von Hubert Aiwanger die sollen also auch
mit seiner Zustimmung wird das
veröffentlicht jetzt im Anschluss
unmittelbar nach dieser Pressekonferenz
es wird auch ins Internet gestellt also
ist dort auch einsehbar Albrecht von
Lucke ist uns immer noch zugeschaltet ja
wenn Luke wir haben ja schon gerade über
das Verhalten gesprochen von Hubert
Aiwanger einerseits Reue zeigen anders
als Angriff auf Medien und politische
Gegner haben Sie eine Vorstellung wie
das jetzt den Wahlkampf in Bayern bis
zum achten Oktober noch beeinflussen
wird
ja das ist die ganz große Frage das was
Markus Söder Herrn Aiwanger ja ein
bisschen in Stammbuch geschrieben hat
oder ihm zur Auflage sagen wir es mal so
gemacht hat war dass er diese Reue auch
zum Ausdruck bringt und da wird ganz
entscheidend sein ob Aiwanger diesen
Vorwurf der Kampagne der
Instrumentalisierung weiter aufrecht
erhält natürlich wird es so sein müssen
wir uns doch nicht vormachen dass
nachdem diese 25 Fragen und Antworten
publiziert werden natürlich eine hitzige
Debatte oder zumindest eine Debatte
einsetzen wird über die Frage hätte
Söder eiwanger entlassen müssen das ist
normal das ist ein journalistischen
Betrieb auch richtig aber ich vermute
ich finde durchaus ja aus richtigen
Gründen hat sich so oder so entschieden
dann könnte diese Debatte abkriegen und
dann wird man sehen ob Hubert ein Wange
davon Abstand nimmt die
Instrumentalisierung zu betreiben das
war natürlich sofort der Versuch
gewissermaßen die opferfrage umzudrehen
sich selber zum Opfer deklar zu
deklarieren das ist natürlich ein
Phänomen wie wir es von Populisten
durchaus kennen Donald Trump als
Speerspitze da wird man also Hubert
alban natürlich auch überprüfen können
ob er die Einsicht hat es nicht
auszuspielen die Versuchung ist für ihn
immer da das wird aber ein Stück weit
auch davon abhängen ob es eine gewisse
Beruhigung in der Causa Albaner gibt und
ob er dann vielleicht tatsächlich selber
das Einsehen hat
wo die es wird in den bayerischen
Bierzelten mutmaßlich jetzt bis zum 8
oktober bei den Wahlkampfveranstaltungen
keinen
Temperaturabfall geben also von locker
letzte Frage zum Thema sie haben es
gerade auch schon angesprochen was die
koalitionsstrategie angeht dass ich
Markus Söder ja jetzt mehr damit auf
gedeiht und Verderb mit dem
Koalitionspartner zusammen tut den
Freien Wählern obwohl es ja vor einigen
Jahren mal so aussah als gäbe auch
schwarz grün möglich er gilt ja als
durchaus geschmeidig der bayerische
Ministerpräsident war so klug sich diese
Strategie jetzt damit irgendwie zu
nehmen da auch auszuwählen denn das
könnte er mutmaßlich nach dem 8 Oktober
sich auch andere Koalitionspartner
auszusuchen beziehungsweise anzusprechen
und vielleicht den einen auch gegen den
anderen auszuspielen
ja absolut insofern sehe ich die
politische Klugheit genau in der letzten
Entscheidung der totalen Absage an
Schwarz-Grün die man ja eigentlich auch
als eine begreifen muss die weit über
den Wahltag hinausgeht als eine nicht
kluge Entscheidung an Markus Söder hat
sich damit ungemein an Aiwanger
gefesselt er ist gewissermaßen nicht
gleich in Geiselhaft aber ist eben sehr
darauf angewiesen dass Hubert Aiwanger
sich jetzt auch so verhält wie er es ihm
nahegelegt hat und das auch keine neuen
Vorfälle aufkommen aber eines will ich
noch dazu sagen es gibt durchaus die
Hoffnung und deswegen bleibt die
Entscheidung ja richtig es gibt die
Hoffnung dass die Sache ein wenig
jedenfalls jetzt anders verläuft das
müssen wir uns alternativ denken als sie
verlaufen wäre wenn Markus Söder
eiwanger entlassen hätte machen wir uns
das einmal bewusst dann wäre Aiwanger
mit den Freien Wählern immer und in
jedem Fall mit dem absoluten Opfer
Mythos durch die Bierzelte gezogen es
hätte einen ungeheuren backlash gegeben
äh das jetzt erst recht der Mann ist
weggeputzt das wäre der schallende Ruf
vieler gewesen und der Volkstribun
Ellwanger hätte das mit Sicherheit
massiv ausgespielt das müssen wir uns
schon bewusst machen insofern trägt
diese Entscheidung ihm an zu lassen
durchaus dazu bei die Lage nicht weiter
zu eskalieren das war natürlich auch die
allergrößte Angst von Markus Söder dass
ihm viele von der Fahne gegangen gewesen
wären möglicherweise wenn er sich anders
entschieden hätten und umso mehr die
Freien Wähler gewählt hätten die ja
sowieso bereits mächtig im Aufwind sind
jetzt eine Schalter die wir noch nach
München geplant haben kommt leider nicht
zustande zu einer Kollegin vom
Bayerischen Rundfunk deswegen bitte ich
Sie also von Luke noch einen Moment
sitzen zu bleiben sie haben es jetzt
auch gerade noch mal bei Aiwanger gesagt
es geht ja auch um Populismus also in
dem Fall um Rechtspopulismus er hat ja
auch sehr kritikwirbelige Äußerungen
gemacht neulich in Erding dass ich die
schweigende Mehrheit die Demokratie
zurückholen soll so als würden wir in
einer Diktatur leben das hat ja auch
Markus Söder massiv kritisiert was
bedeutet denn jetzt diese dieser Fall
diese Affäre diese Diskussion um Hubert
einwanger für die weitere Entwicklung
des politischen Populismus in
Deutschland das ist ja etwas was uns
sehr bedrängt auch in Bezug auf noch
eine andere Partei auch die
bevorstehenden Wahl vor allem in den
nächsten Jahren in Ostdeutschland wie
wer hat daraus Vorteile aus dieser
Diskussion aus diesen Verwerfungen aus
diesen Konflikten um Hubert awanger
ja sie deuten es ja wunderbar an
natürlich ist es ein Stück weit auch die
AFD die mit dem heutigen Tage
triumphiert denn natürlich ist der Grad
zwischen dem was Aiwanger gesagt hat
wir müssen uns die Demokratie die
schweigende Mehrheit muss sich die
Demokratie zurückholen und müssen den in
Berlin dann mal ganz deutlich sagen
halt's Maul das ist natürlich ein Jargon
den man ansonsten von der AFD kennt und
viele werden natürlich Herr höcke dürfte
in Kürze jedenfalls darauf zurückkommen
darauf verweisen dass ein Mann mit
dieser Aussage und natürlich mit diesem
Flugplatz in Bayern weiter
stellvertretender Ministerpräsident
bleiben kann das ist die Hypothek
natürlich und das macht es für die AFD
recht leicht diese Aktion und diese
Geschichte auszuschlachten das ist das
große Dilemma damit hat natürlich zu
allererst Hubert einwanger die Lage der
Demokratie nicht einfacher gemacht
das heißt also wir werden in diesem
Umgang mit eiwagern vielleicht kann man
es auch anders formulieren was müssen
denn zum Beispiel die Medien lernen aus
diesem Umgang mit Hubert Aiwanger und
dem was an Vorwürfen da war was nicht
bewiesen werden konnte jedenfalls nicht
in den wesentlichen Punkten was sollten
die Medien aus dieser aus dieser
Diskussion dieser Affäre um Hubert
Aiwanger lernen ja unbedingt man kann
eines zuallererst lernen eine
Instrumentalisierung die Herr Albaner
jetzt ja getätigt hat wir haben die
Äußerung gehört und bei den fraglich ist
ob es nicht weiter tun wird wird
natürlich ungemein erleichtert wenn ein
solcher Vorfeld ungemein im Vorfeld
einer Wahl einer so entscheidenden
Landtagswahl
publik wird das hätte man natürlich
vermeiden können wenn man es zu einem
weit früheren Zeitpunkt publik gemacht
hätte beispielsweise ein oder zwei Jahre
vor der Wahl das ist ja kein ganz neues
Phänomen man weiß von dieser Causa seit
langem bzw sie schwirrte immer im Raum
das heißt das ist ein Vorwurf und man
wird auch sagen müssen es ist
schwierig wenn die
flugblattgeschichte das flugbad sehr
stark doch mit dem mit der mit der
Aussage schwanger ging es ist von
Aiwanger verfasst ich falte es nicht für
glaubhaft oder für zumindest zweifelhaft
dass Herr Aiwanger nicht möglicherweise
eben doch der Verfasser gewesen ist weil
ein Äußerungen zufolge er weit
rechtsradikaler in den in seiner
Jugendzeit war als sein Bruder Helmut
der offensichtlich eher links und Rock
n' Roll mit langen Haaren orientiert war
aber es geht eben die alte Aussage der
Unschuldsvermutung solange ein Beweis
nicht erbracht werden kann ist es
ausgesprochen schwierig jemanden
aufgrund von Anhaltspunkten an einer
solchen in einer solchen cause zu
kriegen beziehungsweise ihm das Handwerk
wenigstens mal pointiert sagen politisch
zu leben beziehungsweise ihn auch nur zu
überführen das ist alles nicht gelungen
deswegen traf Markus Söder meines
Erachtens aus den richtigen sachlichen
Gründen diese Entscheidung und das hat
es ja ein einfacher auch recht leicht
gemacht das bisher zu
instrumentalisieren und wird ihm auch
weiter die Möglichkeit geben es weiter
zu instrumentalisieren auch
zu Ende vielen Dank Albrecht Publizist
und Journalist Liebe ZuschauerInnen
liebe Zuschauer das war aus aktuellen
Anlass der
die Pressekonferenz die Erklärung von
Markus Söder zur nichtentlassung von
Hubert Aiwanger er bleibt im Amt sie
können ab jetzt im Internet nachlesen
welche Fragen soll der Albaner gestellt
hat welche Antworten hast du wieder
gegeben hat das war's hier mit der
Phönix vor Ort aus aktuellen Anlass
jetzt kommt Phoenix persönlich dass ich
ihn besonders ans Herz legen möchte Eva
Lindenau interviewt Carlo Masala von der
Universität der Bundeswehr in München es
geht natürlich um die deutsche
politische Strategie im Krieg gegen die
Ukraine eine spannende Angelegenheit
bleiben sie bei Phoenix
1323 vor Christus wurde der legendäre
Kind König Tutanchamun in ä